اول شي بنحكي ان الحمد لله اكرمنا واخرجنا
من السجن طبعا حريتنا ما راح تكتمل الا
للافراج عن اخر اسير بسجون الاحتلال فرج
فرج عن اخر اسير بسجون الاحتلال وطبعا
شاعر الفرح مغلفه بالحزن على ابناء شعبنا
بقطاع غزه بنوجه تحيه الوفاء والنصر
لاخواننا بقطاع غزه وبنحكي لهم اليوم حطت
السلاسل خروج لشهداء رغد الفني اليوم
بالمره
ننا طلعنا اول شي بفرحه كثير كبيره بس
بنفس الوقت طلعنا وتركنا ورانا كثير ناس
تركنا ورانا اثيرات لهم سنين وما بنعرف شو
ممكن يصير معهم تركنا ورانا نورهان عواد ش
ابو عياد الخال عاصف البرغوتي ربى العاصي
عهد التميمي تركنا ورانا كثير اسماء كبيره
فهي من جهه من جهه ثانيه انه احنا طلعنا
فعليا على دم في مشكله كثير كبيره في دم
كثير في ناس كثير خسرناهم فشر ملط احنا
لاخر لحظه اليوم من الساعه 8
مشاكل شعورنا صدقا بالمره مش مبول لانه
احنا كنا بشي اقل بكثير من انه يكون
زنازين رسالتي غز ان جك ص احنا كثير اسفين
بالعكس انتم اللي بتعطو القوه مش احنا
احنا كثير صعب انه نحكيلكم اي شي انتم
اللي لازم تحكو